[BLEEP] >> Greg: SAD NEWS
ABOUT CLAY, THOUGH.
SO WHAT SHOULD WE TALK ABOUT
TODAY?
♪ ♪
>> UNHINGED.
>> Greg: IF YOU WANT TO
UNDERSTAND WHY FASCISTS GET INTO
POLITICS, IT'S NEVER MORE CLEAR
THAN WHEN YOU HEAR IT FROM THE
FASCIST.
IT'S NOT JUST BECAUSE THEY WERE
TOO WEAK FOR SPORTS OR TOO UGLY
FOR SHOWBIZ, ALTHOUGH THAT
EXPLAINS ADAM SCHIFF.
IT'S TO GAIN POWER OVER YOU.
AND BECOME EXEMPT FROM THE RULES
THEY ENFORCE ON OTHERS.
THAT'S WHY AS A KID EVERYONE
WANTED TO BE SIMON AND A GAME OF
SIMON SAYS.
IT'S LIKE BECOMING AN ARK WHO
SELLS COCAINE OR A NEW YORK
GOVERNOR WITH FASTER HANDS THANA
BLACKJACK DEALER.
BUT THEN THERE'S CORI BUSH, THE
FIERY BALL OF HYPOCRISY MAKES
MAXINE WATERS SOUND LIKE MAHATMA
GANDHI.
HE OR SHE IS TELLING VOTERS THEY
ARE TO GET FEWER COPS ON THE
BEACH, BUT SHE'S GOING TO GET
MORE SECURITY THAN A BREEZE
CHUCK.
>> YOU CAN'T GET THAT OFF, I'M
GOING TO MAKE SURE I'VE SECURITY
BECAUSE I KNOW I'VE HAD A TEMPS
ON MY LIFE.
AND I'VE TOO MUCH, MUCH WORK TO
DO, TOO MANY PEOPLE WHO NEED MY
HELP RIGHT NOW.
SO IF I END UP SPENT 10,000, TEN
MORE DOLLARS, YOU KNOW IT, I GET
TO BE HERE TO DO THE WORK SO
SUCK IT UP.
WE NEED TO DEFUND THE POLICE AND
PUT THAT MONEY INTO SOCIAL
SAFETY NETS.
>> Greg: I THOUGHT WE WEREN'T
DEFUNDING THE POLICE.
IF THIS WOMEN WERE ANYMORE
UNHINGED, SHE'D BE A SCREEN DOOR
DURING A TORNADO.
SHE SHOULD HAVE JUST SAID I AM
[BLEEP] POWERFUL.
UNLIKE YOU, SHE HAS PRIVATE
SECURED TO BECAUSE HER BODY IS
WORTH BEING ON THIS PLANET RIGHT
NOW.
>> I HAVE PRIVATE SECURITY
BECAUSE MY BODY IS WORTH BEING
ON THIS PLANET RIGHT NOW.
I HAVE PRIVATE SECURITY BECAUSE
THEY COME AT THE WHITE
SUPREMACISTS, RACIST NARRATIVE
THAT THEY DRIVE INTO THIS
COUNTRY, THE FACT
THAT THEY DON'T CARE THAT
THIS BLACK WOMAN THAT HAS PUT
HER LIFE ON THE LINE --
>> Greg: TRUE, BUT THE SAME
COULD BE SAID ABOUT ALL OF THE
OF BODEGAS AND CLOTHING STORES
THAT WERE OTHERWISE DESTROYED
AND THE RIOTS.
OR HOW ABOUT THE BLACK AND BROWN
CASUALTIES ARISING FROM THIS
RELENTLESS CRIME WAVE?
BUT WHO KNOWS, MAYBE SHE WILL
START MAKING SOME SENSE.
>> WHAT OTHER OCCUPATION CAN DO
WORK THAT IS OUT OF THEIR SCOPE
AND STILL BE PROPPED UP TO DO
WORK THAT IS OUT OF THEIR SCOPE?
AS A NURSE, I CAN'T BE THE
SURGEON TOO.
YOU DON'T WANT ME BEING YOUR
SURGEON AND I'M THE NURSE.
AT WHAT POINT DO WE PAY POLICE
TO BE SOCIAL WORKERS -- NO, WE
DON'T.
HOW DID THEY GET TO BE SOCIAL
WORKERS?
>> Greg: THE SOUND OF A BIRD
FLYING INTO A WEED PRESSURE
MAKES MORE SENSE.
BOTTOM LINE, SHE SAYS SHE
DESERVES PROTECTION AND YOU
DON'T.
THE MAFIA DOESN'T LEAVE YOU AT
THE MERCY OF OTHER GAINS AND
THEN BRAG ABOUT IT.
I'M NOT SURE YOU CAN FIND A
TRUER VERSION OF TAKING SHAPE IF
YOU WATCH HOME MOVIES OF
MUSSOLINI.
FOR THE RADICAL TO ASSUME POWER,
THEY MUST FOLLOW THESE THREE KEY
STEPS.
UNDERMINE THE STABILITY OF
INSTITUTIONS THAT KEEP US
SECURE.
CLAIM THEY ARE FOR EQUALITY FOR
THE PEOPLE.
THEN GAIN POWER AND ASSUME
AUTHORITY MINUS THE PREVIOUS
SAFEGUARDS FOR CITIZENS.
THE POLICE THEY VILIFY NO WORK
FOR THEM ONLY.
MEET THE NEW BOSS, WORSE THAN
THE OLD BOSS, BECAUSE THIS BOSS
HAS NO INTEREST IN ACTUAL
EQUALITY.
ONLY PUNISHMENT FOR THIS IS THE
SAME LADY WHO VOWED REVENGE.
AFTER POINTING GUNS AT
TRESPASSING BLM TRESPASSERS.
>> HE IS AN ABSOLUTE LIAR.
HE HAS SPAT ON MY NAME AND
BECAUSE OF THAT, HIS DAY WILL
COME.
>> Greg: HE SPAT ON MY NAME?
HIS DAY WILL COME?
THAT IS PERSONAL SENTIMENT
COMING FROM A POLITICIAN ABOUT A
PRIVATE CITIZEN.
SEEMS A LITTLE CRAZY.
THE THREAT IS CLEAR.
INSULT ONE OF YOUR RULERS, AND
THERE WILL BE HELL TO PAY.
IT'S LIKE "GAME OF THRONES,"
MINUS THE BROTHER SISTER
MARRIAGE.
UNLESS YOU ARE ILHAN OMAR.
IT'S LIKE SNOW SHOVELS THE DAY
BEFORE A NOR'EASTER.
YOU HAVE UNHINGED POLITICIANS
WHO DON'T NEED TO BUY GUNS
THREATENING CITIZENS WHO REALIZE
THE SECOND AMENDMENT MAY BE THE
ONLY PROTECTION THEY HAVE.
THEY ARE TO SHUT DOWN THE
FIRST AMENDMENT AND ARE WORKING
THEIR WAY THROUGH THE LIST.
IT'S LIKE BRIAN STELTER EATING
HIS WAY THROUGH THE MENU AT
McDONALD'S.
NOW SHE CLAIMS SHE GETS DEATH
THREATS, AND I DON'T DOUBT IT.
IF YOU ARE IN THE PUBLIC EYE,
THAT IS A CERTAINTY.
I GET THEM REGULARLY.
ALMOST ALWAYS FROM THE SAME
EMAIL ADDRESS.
BUT AT LEAST, YOU KNOW...
AT LEAST KAT HAS THE DECENCY TO
THREATEN ME IN PERSON.
BUT DO I HAVE A FULL SECURITY
DETAIL?
NO.
WELL YES, IF YOU COUNT MY YELLOW
BELT AND A SLAP FIGHTING PEER
THE RADICALS ARE NO LONGER IN
THE STREETS, THEY ARE NOW IN
OFFICE.
THEY ARE MAKING CHANGES AND THEY
ARE TAKING NAMES.
THEY ARE PROTECTED, YOU AREN'T.
IT'S NOT THE END OF THE WORLD,
BUT WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE
ANYWAY?
DOES IT ALL COME AT ONCE OR IN
DRIPS AND DROPS?
RADICALS ARE REALLY GOOD AT THIS
STUFF.
THEY KNOW AMERICA'S DISTRACTED,
ADDICTED TO THEIR SCREENS WHILE
WE SCROLL, THEY STROLLED RIGHT
IN AND THEY TIED A STONE.
WHILE WE GOT FAT AND RELAXED,
GLUED TO TWITTER AND TICK-TOCK,
THEY OVERTOOK TEACHERS LUNCHES,
HR DEPARTMENTS, GOVERNMENT, AND
THE ONLY THING STANDING BETWEEN
US AND THESE PETTY TYRANTS IS A
DODDERING PRESIDENT WHOSE ONLY
PASSION IS ICE CREAM.
IT'S TIME TO PUT THE PHONE DOWN
AND START STEPPING UP.
IT'S TIME TO GET AS POSTOP AS
THEY ARE PLAYING CANDY CRUSH OR
WORDS WITH FRIENDS AND GOING TO
CUT IT ANYMORE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUEST.
>> Greg: IF YOU WANT TO GET TO
JASPER COMING UP TO GO THROUGH
HER FIRST, COANCHOR AND
"THE FIVE" HOST DANA PERINO!
SHE'S CALLED OUT MARK BULL THAN
A JANITOR AT A RODEO, FOX NEWS
ANCHOR JULIE BANDERAS.
EVEN STARS THINK HIS NAME SOUNDK
SEXTON.
AND SHE'S LIKE A FIGHTER, WIRY
AND FAST, BUT ALSO EATS BUGS AND
LIVES UNDER YOUR BED, KAT.
'S A DAY IN DANA, WELCOME TO THE
SHOW.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE A PERIOD IT
FEELS LIKE I JUST SAW YOU
ALREADY.
SO CLEARLY, SHE SAYS A LOT OF
STUFF, BUT WE'LL GET DEATH
THREATS DID WE ALL WANT TO HAVE
SECURITY.
>> IT MIGHT BE HARD TO BELIEVE,
BUT EVEN I GET DEATH THREATS.
>> Greg: STUART VARNEY IS
STILL PIT STOP AT YOU THAT YOU.
>> I KNOW, I KNOW.
DO YOU REMEMBER WHEN THE
DEMOCRATS WENT AFTER REPUBLICANS
FOR SAYING THEY ARE ALL LIKE
TODD AIKEN?
REMEMBER THAT?
WAY BACK WHEN.
>> Greg: I'M ACHING FOR AN
EXPLANATION.
>> BAD GUY, NOT A GOOD
CANDIDATE, AND NOT
REPRESENTATIVE OF EVERYONE IN
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS -- ANYBODY
WHO SAID THAT THE REPUBLICANS
ARE ALL LIKE TOM AIKEN ARE ALL
GOING TO HAVE A VERY HARD TIME
SAYING THAT SHE DOESN'T
REPRESENT THEM.
WHAT KEVIN McCARTHY, THE
MAJORITY LEADER FOR THE
REPUBLICANS, HE JUST GOT TO SIT
BACK TODAY AND WATCH A CAMPAIGN
BE MADE.
AND JUST YESTERDAY, YOU SAW THE
HEAD OF THE DEMOCRATS SAYING
GUYS, WE HAVE A BIG PROBLEM.
IF THE ELECTION WERE HELD TODAY,
WE WOULD LOSE.
THE TO FUND THE POLICE DOESN'T
WORK.
THEY ARE LOOKING AT -- OBVIOUSLY
ITS TERRIBLE OUTCOME AS WELL,
BUT THEIR POLITICS ARE
ABSOLUTELY TERRIBLE.
>> Greg: WE WERE TOLD BY
EVERYBODY THAT DEFUNDING THE
POLICE WASN'T REALLY DEFUNDING.
>> REMEMBER, PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
TRIED TO SAY THAT IT WAS
ACTUALLY REPUBLICANS WHO WERE
DEFUNDING THE POLICE.
FINALLY "THE WASHINGTON POST" --
>> Greg: JULIE, WELCOME TO THE
SHOW.
I DON'T BELIEVE YOU.
I WANT TO PUT THE STORY AND AN
ANALOGY THAT YOU WILL
UNDERSTAND.
THIS IS LIKE SAYING CRYSTAL METH
SHOULD BE ILLEGAL, EXCEPT FOR ME
BECAUSE I'M A LEADER AND THIS
HELPS ME DEAL WITH MY STRESS.
>> WOW, ALL RIGHT.
SO CRYSTAL METH IS NOT LEGAL,
JUST SO YOU KNOW.
BUT I THOUGHT IT WAS
INTERESTING.
SHE OPENED MY EYES UP TO THIS.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT EVERYBODY AT
HOME, BUT I HAD NO IDEA YOU
COULD GET SECURITY FOR $10.
WHICH THAT MEANS THAT KAT MIGHT
BE ABLE TO AFFORD IT.
AND HERE IN NEW YORK CITY, WE
DON'T NEED GUNS, WE HAVE BRICKS.
AND THOSE ARE PRETTY CHEAP TOO.
I THINK IN THE END WE CAN LOOK
BACK AND SAY, IF YOU HAVE A GUN,
GREAT.
BECAUSE SHE HAS SECURITY DETAIL,
WHICH I BELIEVE ARE ARMED.
BUT IF YOU THINK ABOUT THE
PEOPLE THAT WERE AT THESE BLM
PROTESTS THAT ACTUALLY TRUST ON
THE PROPERTY -- THEY DID NOT GET
CHARGED.
SO WHERE IS CORI BUSH'S UPROAR
ON THAT?
OH, I CAN'T BELIEVE THEY DIDN'T
GET CHARGED FOR TRESPASSING, BUT
THEY CAN'T STAND THERE WITH A
GUN.
IF THEY HADN'T STOOD THERE WITH
A GUN, THEY WILL PROBABLY BE
ROBBED OR LOOTED.
>> Greg: HE WAS AT THAT
PROTEST.
SPEAK I'M NOT SAYING SHE WAS
THROWING BRICKS, BUT LET'S JUST
SAY THAT THESE BLM PROTESTERS
ARE NOT ALL PEACEFUL.
>> Greg: I WAS HIDING IN THE
BUSHES IN NEW YORK CITY.
NOT THE BEST PHRASE AT THIS
POINT, BUT MY WIFE WAS HIDING IN
THE SCAFFOLDING.
BUT WELCOME TO THE SHOW, GOOD TO
SEE YOU.
YOU ARE NOT WALKING YOUR DOG AND
YOUR PAJAMAS.
>> CHANGING IT UP.
>> Greg: SO WHAT DO YOU MAKE
OF THIS?
I HATE SAYING THAT POLITICIANS
ARE HYPOCRITES BECAUSE THAT'S
LIKE SAYING WATER IS WET.
.
BUT THIS IS NOT BREAKING NEW
GROUND.
>> IT'S AMAZING, BECAUSE -- IF
YOU WERE TRYING TO HOLD THE
CONTEST FOR THE DUMBEST
POLITICAL SLOGAN YOU COULD
POSSIBLY COME UP WITH, THIS
WOULD BE PRETTY HIGH UP THERE.
IT'S SO NONSENSICAL.
IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE.
AND WE'VE SEEN THE RESULTS OF IT
NOW.
NOW WE'VE SEEN WHAT'S HAPPENED
IN CITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
IT'S NOT SURPRISING AT ALL.
CORI BUSH, FIRST OF ALL,
AMAZING.
I FEEL LIKE I'M INTERRUPTING
WHAT WE COULD HAVE, WHICH IS
JUST MORE CORI BUSH CLIPS.
BUT YOU KNOW, THERE'S MAIA WILEY
HERE IN NEW YORK.
THEY SAY THEY DON'T WANT TO
DEFUND POLICE.
THEY ACTUALLY -- THERE ARE SOME
ON THE LEFT TO SAY NO, NO.
WE NEED TO CUT POLICE BUDGETS.
MAIA WILEY HAPPEN TO LIVE IN A
$300 MANSION THAT PAYS FOR
SECURITY IN HER NEIGHBORHOOD.
I'M GOING TO BE A HYPOCRITE, I
THINK SHE WOULD BE A BARREL OF
LAUGHS TO HANG OUT WITH.
>> I AGREE.
I WOULD HANG OUT WITH HER AND I
FEEL LIKE I WOULD LEAVE LOVING
MYSELF SO DEEPLY.
BUT I AM CONFUSED, JUST BECAUSE
SHE IS A SELF-DESCRIBED LOUD AND
PROUD DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST,
RIGHT?
BUT YOU KNOW, REMOVING
GOVERNMENT FUNDING FOR POLICE
AND HAVING CITIZENS FUND THEIR
OWN PRIVATE SECURITY IS A
ANARCHICAL CAPITALIST POSITION.
THAT IS LITERALLY THE ANARCHICAL
CAPITALIST MODEL FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
SO I'M CONFUSED BY THAT.
I'M CONFUSED, AS A DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALIST, HOW ARE YOU HAVING --
APPARENTLY A ANARCHICAL
CAPITALIST LIFESTYLE?
>> I'M ALSO CONFUSED, IS SHE A
NURSE OR A DOCTOR?
OR A SURGEON?
>> Greg: IT TOOK ME A WHILE TO
FIGURE OUT THE ANALOGY AND WHAT
SHE IS SAYING YOU CAN'T HAVE
POLICE OFFICERS DOING TWO
DIFFERENT ROLES.
IS THAT WHAT SHE MEANT?
>> THEY ARE DOING LOTS OF ROLES
ALL THE TIME.
BECAUSE THEY SAY WELL, WE NEED
AUXILIARIES TO DO MORE OF THE
RULES THAT THEY CAN'T DO.
SHE ALSO DID NOT GET A SOCIAL
WORKER DETAIL.
>> I WOULD SAY THAT MENTAL
HEALTH WORKERS TEND NOT TO WANT
TO SHOW UP TO RELIEVE
FRIGHTENING SITUATIONS WITHOUT A
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER THERE,
BECAUSE THAT